well if we can apply that
style of empathy style of curiosity to
the current war in Ukraine
what is your understanding of why Russia
invaded Ukraine in February 2022
Vladimir Putin could have avoided the
war in the Ukraine his invasion was
illegal it was unnecessary and it was
brutal
um but I think it's important for us
to move Beyond these kind of comic book
depictions of a uh you know of this
insane uh avaricious
Russian leader who wants to you know
restore the Soviet Empire and that
that's why and it was uh who made it
unfoged unprovoked
um
invasion of the Ukraine he was provoked
and we were provoking them and we were
provoking them for since 1997.
and it's not just me that's saying that
I mean when when and before right before
Putin never came in
we were provoking Russians in this way
unnecessarily
and to go back that time in 1992 when
the Russians moved out of when the
Soviet Union was collapsing
the Russians moved out of East Germany
and they did that which was a huge
concession and they had 400 000 troops
in East Germany at that time and they
were facing NATO troops on the other
side of the wall
Gorbachev made this huge concession
where he said to George Bush
I'm going to move all of our troops out
and you can then reunify Germany under
NATO which was a hostile Army to the to
the South it was created to you know uh
with hostile intent with the Soviet
Union
and he said you can take Germany but I
want your promise that you will not move
NATO to the East and James Baker who was
the Secretary of State famously said
I will not move NATO we will not move
Nato one inch to the east so then five
years later in 1997 this is a big new
Brzezinski who is kind of the father of
the neocons
who's a Democrat at that time served in
the in the uh Carter Administration
he said he published a paper a blueprint
for moving NATO right up to the Russian
border a thousand miles to the east
and and taking over 14 Nations
and at that time George Cannon who was
the kind of the deity of American
diplomats he was probably arguably
arguably the most important Diplomat in
American history
he was the architect of the containment
policy during World War II and he said
this is insane and it's unnecessary and
if you do this it's going to provoke the
Soviet uh I mean the Russians of violent
response and we should be making friends
with the Russians they lost the Cold War
we should be treating them the way that
we treated the our adversaries after
World War II like with a Marshall plan
to try to help them incorporate into
Europe and to be part of the the
Brotherhood of you know of man and of
Western Nations we shouldn't continue to
be treating him as an enemy and
particularly surrounding them at their
borders
William Perry who was then the Secretary
of State of Defense under Bill Clinton
threatened to resign he was so upset by
this plan to move NATO to the ease
and William Burns who is then the U.S
ambassador of the Soviet Union who's now
at this moment the head of the CIA said
at that time the same thing
if you do this it is going to provoke
the Russians toward a military response
and we we moved it we moved all around
Russia we moved to 14 Nations a thousand
miles to the East and we put Aegis
missile systems
in two nations in Romania and Poland so
we did what you know what the Russians
had done to us in 1962 that ever vote
would have provoked the invasion of Cuba
we put those missile systems back there
and then we'd walk away unilaterally
walk away from the two uh nuclear
missile treaties the intermediate
nuclear missile treaties that we had
with the Soviet with Russia
and when neither of us would put on
those missile systems on the borders
we walk away from that and we put Aegis
missile systems which are nuclear
capable they can carry the Tomahawk
missile switch of nuclear warheads so
the last uh country that they didn't
take was the Ukraine and the Russians
said and in effect Bill Perry said this
or William Byrne said it so now the head
of the CIA
it is a red line if we go into if we
bring NATO into Ukraine that is a red
line for the Russians they cannot live
with it they cannot live with it Russia
has been invaded
three times through the Ukraine
the last time it was invaded we killed
or the Germans killed one out of every
seven Russians they destroyed my uncle
described what happened to Russia
um in his famous American University
speech in in uh in 1963
60 years ago this month or he's or last
month 60 years ago in June June 10th
1963. he told that speech was telling
American people put yourself in the
choose the Russians
we need to do that if we're gonna if
we're gonna make peace
and he said all of us have been taught
you know that we won the war but we
didn't win the war the Russians if
anybody won the war against Hitler was
the Russians their country was destroyed
they they all of their cities and he
said imagine if all of the Cities
on the east coast of Chicago were
reduced to rubble and all of the fields
Burns all the force burn that's what
happened to Russia that's what they gave
so that we could get rid of Adolf Hitler
and he had them put themselves in their
position and you know today there's none
of that happening we have refused
repeatedly to uh to talk to the Russians
we've broken up there's two treaties the
Minsk agreements which the Russians were
willing to sign and they said we will
stay out the Russians didn't want the
Ukraine they showed that
when they when the Don BOS region voted
90-10
to leave and go to Russia Boone said no
we want Ukraine to stay intact but we
want you to sign a Memphis Accords to to
you know they the Russians were were
very worried because of the U.S
involvement in the coup in Ukraine in
2014.
and then the oppression and the and the
you know and the killing of 14 000
ethnic Russians and Russia hasn't had
the same reason the same way that if
Mexico
would Age dismissal systems from China
or Russia on our border and then killed
000 expats American we would go in there
oh he does have a national security
interest in the Ukraine he has an
interest in protecting the
russian-speaking people of the Ukraine
yeah I think Russians and the Minsk
accordions at it it left Ukraine as part
of Russia it left him as a
semi-autonomous region that could
continue to use their own language which
is essentially banned by the coup by the
government we put in in 2014.
um and uh and we wouldn't we we
sabotaged that agreement and and then we
now know in April of 2022
and uh Putin had Inked the deal already
to another peace agreement and that the
United States and Boris Johnson the
neocons in the White House and Boris
Johnson over to the Ukraine to sabotage
that agreement so
what do I think I think this is a proxy
war I think this is a you know this is a
war that the neoconsi in the White House
wanted they've said for two decades they
wanted this war
and that they wanted to use Ukraine as a
pawn in a proxy war between uh United
States and Russia the same as we used
Afghanistan
and in fact they say it this is the
model let's use the Afghanistan model
that was set again and again and to to
get the Russians to overextend their
troops and then fight them using local
uh Fighters and U.S weapons
and when President Biden was asked why
are we in the Ukraine he was honest he
says to depose Vladimir Putin regime
change for Vladimir Putin and when his
defense secretary Lloyd Austin in April
2022 was asked you know why are we there
he said to degrade the Russians capacity
to fight anywhere to exhaust the Russian
army and degrade its capacity to fight
elsewhere in the world
that's not a humanitarian Mission that's
not what we were told we were we were
told this was an unprovoked invasion
but
and that we're there to bring a
humanitarian relief to the ukrainians
but that is the opposite that is a war
of attrition that is designed to chew up
turn this little nation into an abattoir
of death for the flower of Ukrainian
youth in order to advance a geopolitical
ambition of certain people within the
White House and uh you know I think
that's wrong
we should be talking to the Russians the
way that you know Nixon talked to
parashnav
the way that bush talked to Gorbachev
the way that my uncle talked to
Khrushchev we need to be talking with
the Russians we should and and and
negotiating and we need to be looking
about how do we end this and preserve
peace in Europe would you as president
sit down and have a conversation with
Vladimir Putin and Vladimir zolensky
separately and together to negotiate
peace absolutely
what about Vladimir Putin
he's been in power since 2000.
so as the old adage goes power corrupts
and absolute power corrupts absolutely
uh do you think he is been corrupted by
being in power for so long if you think
of the male if you look at his mind
listen I don't know exactly
um I can't say because I just I don't
know enough about him or about you know
like my the evidence that I've seen
is that he is homicidal he kills his
enemies or poisons them
and you know the reaction I've seen to
that to hit those accusations from him
have not been to deny that but to kind
of laugh it off I think he's a dangerous
man and that of course you know
um there's probably corruption in his
regime but having said that
it's not our business
to change the Russian government and
anybody who thinks it's a good idea to
do regime change in Russia which has
more nuclear weapons than we do
um is I think irresponsible and you know
Vladimir Putin himself has said you know
we will not live in a world without
Russia and it was clear when he said
that that he was talking about himself
and uh and he has his hand on a button
that could bring you know Armageddon to
the entire planet so why are we messing
with this it's not our job to change
that regime and and we should be making
friends with the Russians we shouldn't
be treating them as an enemy now we've
pushed him into the camp with China
that's not a good thing for our country
and by the way
you know what we're doing now does not
appear to be weakening Putin at all
Putin now you know if you believe the
the polls that are coming out of
Russia
they show him you know the most recent
polls that I've seen
um show him with that 89 popularity that
people in Russia support the war in
Ukraine
and that uh and they supported him as an
individual
so um and I understand there's problems
with polling and you know you don't know
what to believe but but the polls
consistently show that and
um and I you know it's not America's
business to be the policeman of the
world and to be changing regimes in the
world that's illegal or not we shouldn't
be breaking International laws
you know we should actually be looking
for ways
to improve relationships with Russia not
to you know not to destroy Russia not to
destroy and not to choose its leadership
for them that's up to the Russian people
not us so step one is to sit down and
empathize with the leaders of both
Nations to understand their history
their concerns their hopes
just to open the door for conversation
so they're not back to the corner yeah
and I think the U.S can play
a really important role and a U.S
president can play a really important
role by reassuring the Russians that
we're not going to consider them an
enemy anymore that we want to be friends
and it doesn't mean that you have to let
down your guard completely the way that
you do it which was the way President
Kennedy did it is you do it one step at
a time you take baby steps we do a
unilateral move
reduce or you know our
our hostility and aggression and see if
the Russians reciprocate and um and
that's the way that we should be doing
it and you know we should be easing our
way
into a positive relationship with Russia
we have a lot in common with Russia and
we should be friends with Russia and
with the Russian people I mean you know
apparently there's been 350 000
ukrainians
who have died at least in this war and
uh and there's probably been uh 60 or 80
000 Russians and that should not give us
any Joy it should not give us any you
know I saw
Lindsey Graham on TV saying you know
anything we can something to the extent
that anything we can do to kill Russians
is a good use of our money that it is
not you know those are those are
somebody's children they're you know we
should have compassion for them this war
is an unnecessary War we should settle
it through negotiation through diplomacy
through statecraft
and not through weapons do you think
this war can come to an end purely
through military
operations no I mean I don't think
there's any way in the world that the
ukrainians can beat the Russians I don't
think there's any appetite in Europe I
think Europe is now you know uh in
having severe problems in Germany Italy
France you're seeing these riots there's
internal problems in those countries
there is no appetite in
um in uh in Europe for sending men to
die in Ukraine and the ukrainians do not
have anybody left the ukrainians are
using press gangs too uh to you know to
fill the ranks of their armies men a
military age men
are trying as hard as they can to get
out of the Ukraine right now to avoid
going to the front the front you know
the Russians apparently have been
killing ukrainians in a seven to one
ratio
my son fought over there and he told me
it's not you know artillery he had
um he had fire fights with the Russians
mainly at night but he said most of the
battles were artillery wars during the
day and that the Russians now out uh
outgun the NATO forces ten to one in
artillery
oh they're killing at a horrendous rate
now you know my interpretation of what's
happened so far is that the
Putin actually went in early on
with a small Force because he expected
to meet somebody on the other end of a
negotiating table that once he went in
and uh and that when that didn't happen
they did not have a large enough Force
to be able to mount an offensive and so
they've been building up that Force up
until now and they now have that force
and even against this small original
Force the ukrainians have been uh
helpless
all of their offenses have died they've
now killed you know the head of the
Ukrainian um
Special Forces which was the probably
arguably by many accounts the best uh
Elite military unit in all of Europe
the the command common death the
commander of of the uh That Special
Forces Group
uh gave a speech about uh four months
ago saying that 86 percent of his men
are dead or wounded and will cannot
return to the front he cannot rebuild
that for us
um the uh and you know the the the
troops that are now headed that are now
filling the gaps of all those 350 000
men who've been lost
are are scandily trained and they're
arriving green at the front any of them
do not want to be there many of them are
giving up and going over the Russian
side we've seen this again and again
again including platoon-sized groups
that are defecting to the Russians
and
um I don't think it's possible to win
and anybody you know I saw I I of course
I've studied World War II history
exhaustively I mean I saw a
um there's a new I think it's a Netflix
series of documentaries that I highly
recommend to people there it's they're
colorized versions of the black and
white
um films from the battles of World War
II but it's all the battles of World War
II so I watched Stalingrad
the other night and uh you know the the
willingness of the Russians to
um to fight on against any kind of outs
and to make huge sacrifices
of Russians the Russians themselves who
were making the sacrifice with their
lives the willingness of them to do that
for their motherland is almost
inexhaustible It is incomprehensible
to think that the uh that Ukraine can
can beat Russia in a war it would be
like Mexico beating the United States
it's just it's impossible to think that
it can happen and you know Russia has
deployed
a tiny tiny fraction of its military so
far and uh you know now it has China
with its mass production capacity
supporting its war effort it's just
it's a it's a hopeless situation and
we've been lied to you know we're the
press in our country and our government
are just are just you know promoting
this lie that the ukrainians are about
to win and everything's going great and
that
pollutants on the run and there's all
this wishful thinking because of the the
Wagner group you know the uh the Goshen
and the Wagner group that this was an
internal coup and it showed descent and
weakness of Putin and none of that is
true I was a that that
Insurgency which wasn't even an
Insurgency he only got four thousand of
his of his men to follow him out of
twenty thousand
and they were quickly stopped and nobody
in the Russian military the oligarchy
the political system nobody supported it
you know and by we're being told oh yeah
it's the beginning of the end for blue
Putin
he's weakened he's wounded he's on his
way out and all of these things are just
lies that we are being fed then push
back on a small aspect of this he kind
of implied so I've traveled to Ukraine
and one thing that I should say similar
to the Battle of Stalingrad it is just
not is not only the Russians that fight
to the end I think Ukrainian is a very
yeah to fight to the end and the morale
there is quite High I've talked to
nobody this was a year ago in August
with her son
everybody was proud to fight and die for
their country and there's some aspect
where this war unified the people to get
gave them a reason and an understanding
that this is what it means to be
Ukrainian and I will fight to the death
I you know I would agree with that and I
I should have said that myself at the
beginning but you know that's the reason
my son went over there to fight because
the you know he was inspired by The
Valor of the Ukrainian people and the
you know this extraordinary willingness
of them and I think Putin thought it
would be much easier to sweep into
Ukraine and he found you know a stone
wall of ukrainians whether it read it
but they're
their lives and their bodies online but
that to me makes the the whole episode
even more tragic is that you know
um I don't believe I I you know I I
think that the U.S role in this
um has been uh has you know that there
were there were many opportunities
to settle this war and The ukrainians
Wanted America's landscape when he ran
in 2019. here's a guy who's a a comedian
he's a he's an actor
um he had no political experience and
yet he won this election with 70 of the
vote why he went on a peace platform
anyone promising to sign the mystical
courts and yet something happened when
he got in there that made him suddenly
pivot and you know I think
it's a good guess what happened I think
he was you know he came under Threat by
Ultra natural and nationalists within
his own Administration
uh and the insistence of neocons like
Victoria new and the White House that
you know we don't want peace with Putin
we want a war
do you worry about nuclear war yeah I
worry about it it's uh it seems like a
silly question but it's not
it's a serious question well the reason
it's not you know the reason it it I
might it's not is just because people
seem to be in this kind of dream state
about that it'll never happen
and yet you know we're uh it can happen
very easily and it can happen at any
time and you know if we push the
Russians too far you know I I don't
doubt that Putin if he felt like his
regime was in or his Nation
was in danger that the United States was
going to be able to
place you know a quizling on you know in
into the Kremlin
um that he would use nuclear you know
torpedoes
um and uh you know these uh these
strategic weapons that they have and
that could be the end once you do that
nobody controls the trajectory